le rassemblement national s'appelle
rassemblement national donc il ya
quelque chose qui l'exclût d'une
certaine façon en principe du local même
s'il faut être attentif
parmi les théoriciens actuelle du
rassemblement national vous avez juin
qui est inquiétant ce fervent partisan
du localisme et donc il ya une stratégie
de reconquête locale qui est en train de
se mettre en oeuvre qui n'a pas réussi
ce coup ci mais voilà pour la suite il
va falloir être attentif à 7 à cette
évolution pourrait dire un mot sur
l'idée que l'élection se serait pas le
lieu de la vie démocratique et la
vitalité démocratique faut pas oublier
une chose c'est que l'élection c'est pas
simplement les gens qui évoque l'
abstention de gens qui votent c'est
aussi ce qui se présente
neuf cent mille candidats se présentent
en france 600 mille élus c'est à dire un
français sur sont à peu près est élu
donc c'est un truc incroyable c'est le
record du monde en comptant donc dit la
démocratie participative eux repris un
titre
candace marche pas c'est juste une vaste
truanderie où nous avons une démocratie
représentative qui est déjà extrêmement
participative 6 600 mille élus donc de
ce point de vue là rappelons aussi les
choses l'élection continue d'être la
matrice de la vie démocratique en france
[Musique]